تبدو قضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها
الرئيس الحالي جو فايدن والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب مؤشرا على مشكله حقيقيه
تواجهها اجهزه الدوله الامريكيه مع
الرؤساء الامريكيين
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
كشفها كيف يتم التعامل مع الوثائق المصنفه
الذريه
وانا اقرا ثم يستعيدها ويضعها في الحقيبه
ويغادر
لكن المساله مختلفه مع الرئيس الامريكي من
الممكن ان نرى الرئيس سبايدر وهو يغادر
وبيده اوراق ويذهب الى مقر الاقامه في
المبنى الرئيسي من البيت الابيض او الى
الطائره لا احد يتابع مع الرئيس الامريكي
ما حصل للاوراق المصنفه السريه
ولا احد يسال عنها او يطلب استعادتها من
الرئيس عندما يغادر او عندما ينتهي من
استعمالها هذه واحده من المشاكل لكن ما
حصل مع بيضه ومن قبله ترامب يتراوح بين
الاهمال والاصرار على عدم احترام
الاجراءات الامنيه وحمايه الوثائق السريه
فبعض الوثائق موجود بحوزه بايضا منذ كان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وقبل ان يصبح
نائبا للرئيس العام
طبعا يجب ان يتبعه نظام المكتبات العامه
وعندما يعطى الرئيس وثيقه وهي عاده تاتي
من السي اي اي او وزاره الدفاع يجب ان
تكون مسجله ومرقمه
الحل الاخر المطروح هو تحويل
الكره السريه الى النظام الالكتروني
وبالتالي يقفل الدخول اليها بمجرد انتهاء
الرئيس من استعمالها وهذا ما حصل في
الاجاز الامني للرئيس في المكتب البيضاء